[Music]
in myth farewell news bye-bye
submitted by Bob from Texas hi Texas oh
I'd like to thank you hey a man through
a meth fueled death party for his wife
before she died huh oh did she die from
meth - oh [ __ ]
so wait they had a bun okay wait so they
party and get a bunch of meth and for
she had to go and die I think she was
about to die - is that drug might as
well a party and they did hell a meth
meth is the stuff that was on Breaking
Bad yeah yeah okay and it's the it is
the glass-like object yeah crush into
something and see that glass pipe meth
and crack is the same thing no no no
nope what's crack crack is made out of
cocaine you know slip chemicals I don't
know what that's made of ice I think
it's made of like sudafed and [ __ ] and
like all kinds of other chemicals it's
crack cocaine and cocaine different but
yes oh really so like okay cocaine comes
from the coca leaf in in South America
they be from chocolate no chocolate it's
like it's like a plant it's like a it's
like a brown big thing but it's not the
same no it's a it's a it's a yeah coco
coco or something like that yeah it's
it's a leaf right and then they crush
the leaf and then they turn that into
like a they process it turn it into
powder form okay when you get that
that's what people use to snort you
don't smoke cocaine mm-hmm and but then
they figured out a way to make this a
cheaper smokeable form in the 80s and it
hits you harder faster and that's when
they mix it with baking soda like a
baking soda see that's why they do that
[ __ ] and then there's just this process
where you cool it down and do that and
it turns into this rock form so it's
cocaine processed into rock and when you
get the rock one you smoke that one
cocaine you snorted if you you can't
like crush the rock and start it I've
never seen anyone do that it's crack
cocaine the one that makes people like
de la crazy take off their clothes and
run around and [ __ ] that's probably
angel dust or PCP
yeah because that's the one where people
were doing that and they were like
pretty much jumping off of buildings and
kicking like yeah car doors and breaking
them and it flies there yeah yeah that's
like I think that one's derived from
like a tranquilizer or something I don't
know what that one is but yeah get it
mad at first in drugs I'm learning so
much fear I'm not a thought about it you
know and if they have different effects
to like meth is totally different it's
if anyone's tried adderall it has the
same chemical compound as
methamphetamine so it's very similar oh
the weight but it's not made from the
same thing it's a synthetic one that's
made differently yeah and I don't know
why but people were like controlling how
much sudafed is sold because people we
use that to also make meth
there's like some chemical [ __ ] but then
the difference is math you just kind of
take it and you feel super hype and then
like you just can't sleep and whatever I
never tried coke I only smoked rocks
which is crack and that one is a very
different feeling you smoked meth yeah
it's this it's the same like I mean how
does that mean you can snort it you can
snort speed but then the same thing
speed so the names of a speed yeah speed
meth shab [ __ ] there's different kind
of names for it what's crystal crystal
matter still meth crystal
methamphetamine that's yeah how does
that make you feel what is the what is
the effect of it you know like maybe if
it affected me differently because I
would smoke it multiple times and then I
would just be like alert and then I
would just be alert and happy maybe
that's all we lost the og Joe and then
you just went like this joke no that was
acid
[Laughter]
you're like a [ __ ] Russian nesting
doll did but the rushing that's ugly
ugly ugly dick for some crazy thing
though those two drugs are known to be
really a dick addictive right like it's
one of the most it destroys lives a lot
of my friends like they went brain-dead
or like they got into jail because like
they ran out of money and they needed to
steal I never got there I just didn't
understand I just did it because other
people did it and I was a recreational
it was recreational I like I was never
like sadly some [ __ ] crack IV some
crack like I never got there like I
don't know maybe maybe my brain just
didn't get addicted to that my [ __ ] was
weed I loved Webelos it maybe your
brains like you think you crazy I'm
crazy or [ __ ] yeah but I also
did in this [ __ ] I don't remember the
way my meth experience was was totally
different from everyone else so it could
be that it just affected my brain
differently that's amazing all right
well this man here this man named Wayne
was 58 years old from Minnesota me nice
ol Minnesota so he checked his wife out
from a nursing home her name is Debra
she's 69 years old she was really sick
and he says that she wanted to die at
home and so they she stopped taking her
medications they took meth together they
spent her final hours having sex and
rocked out to their favorite metal band
called Quiet Riot
fun actually yeah yeah and so he was
saying that Debra couldn't eat or drink
and so he used snow to moisten her mouth
and but then she started having
convulsions and but she would not he
says that she would not let him call the
police so he after she died he washed
her body and wrapped her in linen quote
like the Bible told me to do oh he then
waited several hours
for calling 9-1-1 and so when he did
call 9-1-1 he so he went outside and say
that she's and yell out that his wife
had died he was naked
sounds like meth behavior um and that's
all you ran back in to take a bath and
then the cops found him in the bathtub
hallucinating trying to wash white and
black things from his skin and they also
spray-painted on the front door death
hard a God health they really spray pain
or death in his mind spray-painted on
the front door who's they come in around
a couple Oh how many days ago did it
start they don't mention that you know
most people that hallucinate and start
going crazy on meth it's because they
don't sleep it's not really the drug
that makes lack of sleep yeah yeah so
it's the upper you can't sleep on it the
story started off kind of sweet and then
you got a little crazy
you ready okay let's see if it matches
my image oh [ __ ] well he's still on it
right there he's gotta come down yet oh
[ __ ] yeah it's interesting when old
people do meth thing go ahead like a
strand of hair I don't picture old
people like metal sad and metal metal
yeah like why did I picture like younger
kids or age it's just hard to imagine
she was 69 he's 58 he looks 90 or
something yeah that's what meth does to
you that bull worm in the spongebob
episode oh yeah when I picked up my
friend from the airport I also picked up
his dad well funny thing is they didn't
even know they were on the same [ __ ]
flight to come to LA but I picked them
both up when I when I picked up that his
dad I thought that was his grandpa
because his dad did hell at drugs I
thought it was his [ __ ] grandpa
he was like and he passed away actually
pretty early was a asian asian asian -
and then he passed away in his 50s but
he looked like he was in his 80s oh I
thought that was his grandfather and he
actually has a twin so you could see
what he's supposed to look like oh you
could see what he would look like till
this day if he didn't do drugs when he
sees his twin I don't know he will he
passed away but like it's it's kind of
sad because you just you could see the
effect of what that drug does to you
yeah have you seen those before and
after pics is [ __ ] crazy their
eyebrows always get worse it's coke too
and then they get spots because they're
never you a source on their face I never
seen like before-and-after stoner ones
like if I see it it's probably just like
tired I'm gonna bag of talk about oh
yeah this whole world is just full of
addictive [ __ ] dude and we don't even
know what we're [ __ ] addicted to
what's happening takes it away
tell me of my phone not even just just
[ __ ] [ __ ] potato chips or some
[ __ ] you didn't you're nuts leave okay
that's addicting it is a big things in
addiction huh
sex addiction she's small things
anything that makes you feel good
anything try me - I've been addicted to
it you know how much time I wasted
looking at them I'll be working and I
turn around and I'm like hey look at
what she's doing look at me and she's
just like look at how she looks
yeah one of my viewers got me is shirt
this is can I pet your dog best in the
world you pet every single dog you meet
like sometimes I look at people and
sometimes they just look like they don't
want to be bothered and I get so sad cuz
I want to pet their dog there's this
Instagram that I heard
when I was listening to the radio it's
this 12 year old boy yeah his Instagram
handle is I I've had that dog yeah he'll
like pet the dog and then he'll write
like a little like the caption will say
like this is Savannah she's old like
human in New York but for yeah yeah and
he's always like with them that's my
dream do I just want to go and pet every
dog some doesn't weird my dog my
brother's dog moon yuck I [ __ ] hated
walking her because she she has to lick
every person that she's not even like
like come up and say hi she's got boxes
she goes walks it just goes next to him
so there's like [ __ ] weird dude had a
lick everybody's [ __ ] ankle dude oh
yeah [ __ ] like a foot addiction speech
she [ __ ] loves feet that's why
[ __ ] crackhead shits the crackhead of
the dogs her eyes look crazy - yeah you
ever seen those stinky ass dogs and then
they want attention is [ __ ] disgusting
I'll be like I get my finger and I just
[ __ ] to rub their forehead like this
hi-yah
don't [ __ ] touch me yeah they smell
like [ __ ]
you're that dog my sister brought home
was [ __ ] amazing oh you sure you
can't bat [ __ ] - [ __ ] I
think what was that like a like a mm-hmm
you mix up a lot of weird things like it
looked like a mini golden tree rat I was
stretched out in [ __ ] core deed very
corny
[Music]
you
[Music]